Tenemos dos figuras tridimensionales diferentes
aquí: a la izquierda tenemos una pirámide,
mientras que a la derecha tenemos un cono. Y
ya sabemos algunas cosas al respecto de estas
dos figuras. Primero, podemos observar que ambas
tienen exactamente la misma altura, esta longitud
que tenemos por acá es h y esta otra longitud
que va desde el pico hasta el centro de la base
también es h. Además sabemos que el área de las
bases es la misma, por ejemplo, el área de la
base de esta pirámide de la izquierda es x • x, si
suponemos que es un cuadrado, x • x, entonces el
A = x², el área de esta base es x²; y el área de
esta otra base de aquí será igual a πr². Además,
estamos diciendo que estas dos áreas son iguales,
es decir, también sabemos que x² = πr². Ahora
bien, te tengo una pregunta: ¿estas dos figuras
tendrán el mismo volumen o será distinto?, y en
dado caso de tener volúmenes distintos ¿qué figura
tiene un volumen mayor? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Muy bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Dado que
estamos trabajando con dos figuras que tienen la
misma altura y la misma área de la base, podríamos
pensar que es útil el Principio de Cavalieri. Si
recordamos que el Principio de Cavalieri dice que
si tenemos dos figuras -en esta ocasión estamos
trabajando con figuras en tres dimensiones, es
decir, estamos pensando en una versión de tres
dimensiones del Principio de Cavalieri-, nos dice
que, si tenemos dos figuras con la misma altura y
en cualquier punto a lo largo de su altura el área
de la sección transversal es la misma, entonces
las figuras tienen el mismo volumen. Entonces, lo
que necesitamos hacer es descifrar si realmente
en cualquier punto de sus alturas ambas figuras
tienen la misma área de la sección transversal.
Bueno, para pensar en esto tomemos un punto
arbitrario a lo largo de sus alturas, y sólo por
simplicidad tomemos la mitad de la altura, aunque
podríamos hacer este análisis en cualquier punto a
lo largo de sus alturas. Aquí estamos a la mitad
de esta altura y por acá estamos a la mitad de
esta otra altura, por lo tanto, esta distancia que
tenemos aquí mide h / 2 y esta otra distancia que
tenemos aquí mide h / 2, ya que la altura completa
mide h. Y lo que podemos hacer es construir lo que
parecen ser dos triángulos semejantes; de hecho,
vamos a demostrar que, en efecto, son triángulos
semejantes. Vamos a construirlos por aquí, y
sabemos que son semejantes porque esta recta será
paralela a esta otra recta, y esta otra recta es
paralela a esta otra recta, es decir, al radio. ¿Y
cómo lo sabemos? Porque las áreas de las secciones
transversales que estamos tomando son paralelas
a la base, son paralelas a la superficie. En
ambos casos, estas secciones transversales van
a ser paralelas y, por lo tanto, estas líneas que
están sobre estas secciones transversales, están
sobre la base y sobre esta sección transversal
también deben ser paralelas. Y dado que estas son
rectas paralelas, entonces este ángulo debe de ser
congruente a este ángulo, este otro ángulo debe de
ser congruente a este otro ángulo, ya que estas
son transversales a través de rectas paralelas,
y estos sólo son ángulos correspondientes, y
por supuesto comparten este ángulo en común.
Por acá podemos ver claramente que tenemos un
ángulo recto, por acá tenemos otro ángulo recto,
este ángulo es congruente a este otro ángulo
y ambos triángulos comparten este ángulo. Por
lo tanto, en ambos casos, este triángulo pequeño
es semejante al triángulo más grande. Y esto nos
ayuda a darnos cuenta que la razón entre los
lados correspondientes es la misma. Entonces,
si la altura completa es h y esta otra altura es h
/ 2, es decir, es la mitad de la altura completa,
esto nos dice que este lado tiene que ser la
mitad del radio, así que este lado mide r / 2;
por el mismo argumento, este lado de aquí mide
x / 2. Por lo tanto, ¿cuánto mide el área de
la sección transversal por aquí? Bueno, será
(x / 2)², x entre 2 esto elevado al cuadrado,
que es lo mismo que x² / 4 que es 1/4 del área
de la base, mide 1/4 del área de la base. ¿Y
qué hay de esta área de esta sección transversal?
Bueno, esta área de la sección transversal será
igual a π (r/2)², que es lo mismo que πr² / 4,
o podemos decir que esto es igual a 1/4 πr²,
que podemos observar de nuevo que es 1/4 del
área de la base. Si el área de la base es πr²,
entonces 1/4 πr² es 1/4 del área de la base, y,
como mencionamos, el área de la base de estas dos
figuras es la misma. Entonces, acabamos de ver
que las áreas de la sección transversal en este
punto de la altura es igual en ambas figuras; y
podríamos hacer lo mismo para un punto que esté
a 1/4 a lo largo de la altura o a 3/4 a lo largo
de la altura, obtendríamos exactamente el mismo
análisis: tendríamos dos triángulos semejantes
y podríamos ver que tenemos las mismas áreas de
secciones transversales en ese punto de la
altura. Y, por esta razón, por el Principio
de Cavalieri en tres dimensiones, podemos ver
que estas dos figuras tienen el mismo volumen.
Lo que es interesante de esta idea es que
nos permite tomar la fórmula para el volumen
de una pirámide, que ya hemos demostrado e
intuido en otros videos, que nos dice que:
el volumen de una pirámide es igual a 1/3 b • h,
y ver que, en efecto, este cono tiene exactamente
el mismo volumen, este volumen también es igual
a 1/3 b • h, ya que en ambos casos el área de la
base es la misma y la altura también es la misma.
Entonces, sabemos que tienen el mismo volumen.